[Music]
one of our most
basic human needs sex
but when coronavirus has made something
as simple as a
kiss or a hug taboo we're so used to
interacting with people and having touch
and without that right now you know we
we're really at a loss
so how can we get the physical intimacy
we need
experts have offered advice from who we
should be doing it with
to how we should be doing it for many of
us
sex has become a burden for others
a real problem
someone once told me purple means
sexually frustrated
desperate times call for desperate
measures but which measures are the
right ones
here's some advice from my colleague and
sexpert kaz
at the 77 dw's youth show for africa
because i could traffic is crazy what is
it what's going on what's happening talk
to me
uh i honestly can't take it anymore josh
is driving me crazy
okay details what's happening well you
know we've been
together for like almost a year now and
everything was going great
but once the lockdown started things
just started to change with him
especially after he lost his job
sounds like he's grieving i don't know i
can't imagine what he's going through is
easy
but i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying i've i've tried
i've tried to make him comfortable about
the situation i'm still able to cover
the bills but
i just don't get it he's become so
distant he sits in front of the tv all
day
we haven't had sex in months i just
don't know what to do
have you tried having an open
conversation with him i can barely get
him to tell me what he'll have for
dinner you think he wants to talk about
this
that's a tough one but also quite common
i mean i think josh
might be depressed yeah maybe a form of
intervention might help
get someone professionally preferably
come to you sit have a conversation
between the two of you
you know i guess like yo some men
struggle to open up because they think
it makes them look
weak and we have the patriarchy to thank
for that maybe he feels like he can no
longer
act as the provider which also
traditionally
is expected of men but
he needs to learn that he's still valued
like give him time
like an opportunity to heal i think
that's the best you can do but what if
nothing
changes or if he refuses to listen then
it's on you you have to decide if
it's the kind of environment you want to
foster a relationship in otherwise what
will happen next time things go
tough you need to take care of your own
mental health too
yeah i suppose that makes sense
but what about the sex i'm dying
pull out your vibrator sis it's totally
normal to lose your sex drive when
you're suffering from depression believe
me
but be patient with him you know but in
the meantime
you can meet your own needs okay okay
yeah okay that makes sense that okay
enough about me
how about you how are you dewey oh
i'm getting laid sale
researcher raquel peel joins us from my
hometown brisbane
raquel good to see you there tell me is
your best sexual partner
yourself during these difficult times
well it depends are you a single person
looking for someone new or are you
already in a relationship
so if you're single what do you reckon
well if you're single then you've really
got to consider the safety issue
with the pandemic so i guess for me it
doesn't necessarily mean that you
are your best partner if i want to have
sex with someone i would be wanting to
have that conversation about
safety have they been checked for
coronavirus
would they consider getting checked
prior to engaging in sexual activity
but isn't that something that will scare
people away
look when it comes to love and
relationships anything
will scare us away if we are willing to
go away but i think if you if this is
something that you
want i think that conversation is
warranted
it's the same conversation around safe
sex wearing condoms
it's we need to have that conversation
what about what the
terence higgins trust uh advised in the
uk back in
august last year to avoid kissing
wear a face covering and choose
positions that aren't
face to face during sex that sounds a
little complicated
it really does and i think it's the the
advice that i would give
is have a conversation it's a lot more
logical
to to talk about safety to be open with
your partners
around whether you've been tested around
the way you would consider being tested
those considerations to avoid intimacy
that's just not feasible it's not
something that we can as human beings do
for too long
we are intrinsically motivated to
connect and i think the better advice is
let's connect in a safe manner
how long is it healthy to abstain from
sex
look i don't have that number for you i
would just say look again
as humans we are intrinsically motivated
to do it
so being told that we can't do it i
don't think that's the right thing
the right thing would be how do we do it
raquel what about
cyber sex
why not it's intimacy the key element is
intimacy we can be intimate online
so i think that's a good alternative
especially for couples that have been
separated by the pandemic
to keep up the intimacy i would say
online sex but also conversation
so it's it's a way to keep connected any
i have actually heard from people
who have been kept apart but found other
ways to connect
that their relationship actually got
better
how how how did it get better can you
give me some examples
yeah it got better because well one they
had to be a little bit more creative
with how they connected
not necessarily just sex but also
communication and in that communication
they were able to
tell each other what they like and don't
like and sometimes
in in in when we are together in the
heat of sex without we might not be able
to communicate what we want
but in that online environment they had
that opportunity to communicate and say
well i like this i don't like that
more on couples lots of couples are in
crisis right now it's a
pressure cooker scenario how can you
save a relationship in times like these
yeah it's it's it's look couples who are
in conflict right now
are couples who already had conflict in
their relationship
and because of the pandemic those
conflicts sort of came to surface
one thing that i often say is to watch
for the ratio
of interaction that you have with your
partner so it should be a ratio between
five to one
so for ever one negative thing negative
interaction that you have with your
partner you need five positive
interactions so balance the interactions
of your partner think about how you
communicate with them
meaning that instead of using you
statements so you don't do this or
you make me you know upset about this
use
i statements talk about yourself and how
you feel turn things around so you can
address conflict
raquel can you just leave us with one
more piece
of advice that'll get us through this
crisis
make us perhaps a little less frustrated
yeah um one piece of advice
i think i think if safety is the thing
that it's bothering
bothering you have a conversation with
your partner about safety i often hear
people talk to me about
how how do i be safe how do i change
things have a conversation with your
partner
of what it is to be safe change your
routine if need be
because if you are going to be locked
down you need to start communicating a
lot more
you heard it from raquel peale thank you
very much for joining us today
a look at some of the numbers now and
we're around the 2
million mark of officially recorded
cover deaths worldwide
that's according to figures from the
johns hopkins university
the united states accounts for nearly
one in five
deaths globally as you can see there
it's followed by
brazil and india mexico and the uk
and looking at the countries with the
highest proportion of deaths in a
population
san marino has more than 1900 deaths per
million
belgium is next then slovenia
italy and bosnia and heads of governor
time for your questions on the
coronavirus over to our science
correspondent derek williams
should pregnant women get these new
vaccines
i've often been asked how dangerous
covet 19
can be for a pregnant woman or her
unborn baby
and i've talked about that topic a few
times
over the last 10 months but i've never
discussed
this aspect of it whether trying to
prevent
catching the disease could pose a danger
so
so let's look at what reliable sources
are saying
about vaccines and pregnancy i think
the most important thing to be aware of
is that we
just don't have as much information on
pregnant women receiving
approved covit 19 vaccines as we do for
other groups
because women who knew they were
pregnant weren't included in the
large-scale trials that led to emergency
vaccine approvals
of course some women became pregnant in
the course of those trials
um and i found no reports indicating
that they
or their unborn babies suffered any ill
side effects attributable
to a vaccine candidate but the fact is
we still simply know less about what
might happen to a pregnant woman being
vaccinated
than we do about other groups so so so
that's quite rightly
causing health care authorities to to
adopt a cautious approach
uh the general consensus among leading
organizations
including the who and the cdc
is that there's still just not enough
evidence to
recommend covet 19 vaccines
to pregnant women on a wide scale but
they also make exceptions for women at
increased
risk of exposure for example frontline
healthcare workers
those women may consider being
vaccinated
after talking to an expert about
everything we know so far about covid19
and pregnancy that's because we also
know
that pregnant women are in more danger
of developing
severe forms of the disease if they
catch it
if women from those high exposure groups
choose to be vaccinated
and agree to be tracked their data
will flow into further studies which
should in the near future
tell us a lot more about any possible
dangers
many experts currently seem optimistic
though that the benefits of vaccines
will outweigh any risks for pregnant
women too
but the jury is still out
you